The following is a production of Frank DeFreys and the Internet Red Zion of Holography.
Hello and welcome to the season finale of HoloTalk.
For the final show of the season, I thought it would be a nice idea to look back and highlight many of the shows that were broadcast this season.
For the summer months, I will replay these shows in their entirety for those listeners who either never had the chance to hear them originally and for those who would like to listen again.
Holo Talk will return with a new season of shows on September thirteenth, right after Labor Day.
To start off, I spoke with Paul Graham of Light Vision early in the season and asked him if he could share the technique of putting holograms on edible foods.
In this particular case, lollipops.
Here's what he had to say.
Without giving any secrets out that you obviously have to hold on for your own protection of doing this and inventing this technology with you know your company.
Um could you tell some of the listeners what goes into putting a holographic image on a lollipop?
Um, yes, I can.
Um well basically the history of the hologram was that it was invented by a physicist at uh MIT.
His name's Eric Bakelder, and Eric is actually a principal of our company.
Uh he actually still handles all the holography work for us.
Eric had discovered that he could impart images on food products.
So basically what he devised was a system where he can cut little tiny grooves in the surface of the food.
Mm-hmm.
What happens is the light comes in and reflects off these grooves and forms an image in your eye.
Just just the way things happen with sort of like an embossed hologram.
Basically, it's a it's a very similar sort of process.
Um this you you're able to do this with uh pops I believe because something to do with the sucrose or something being almost like a plastic?
Yeah basically I mean basically most food most food um like flour, starches and sugars, um are really sort of natural form of plastic.
I mean they're not a stable form, but they effectively work like a plastic I mean glasses a as you know with embossed holograms the forming um glass is actually uh also sort of like a plastic type agent.
So Eric sort of postulated that he could use food similar to uh using metals or glass or anything else and um it tends to work.
On another show, Wang Hunter Chun of holographic development corporation in Shen, China told HoloTalk listeners how holography is currently used in China.
Mm-hmm.
How are holograms used in China?
Are they used in magazines or packaging?
The hologram in China commonly used only for the label on some small packets.
I see.
That's that's what we can see uh anywhere.
I think uh in US and the other countries it's also you know like some in both labels.
Yes in both takes almost ninety nine percent in China.
And uh usually they are very small.
They are one to two uh centimeters squares.
And uh you know I can find uh some bigger ones in abroad but in China it's only small ones.
Actually we never see any other use uh like in the magazine cover or books or any any package.
The in the package they have some not hologram, they have some uh shiny materials like uh hologram papers for We took a virtual trip up to Victoria, British Columbia and visited the holography shop of Derek Gallon.
He told us about his Russian holograms on exhibit at Royal Holographic Gallery.
Frank, we try to have as much as uh as possible of different artists on a different hologram product.
We try to find uh new products, we constantly search for them.
That's the reason we are able to show uh quite unique Russian holograms.
We started uh the partnership with uh Russian holographers more or less uh three years ago.
We have a constant display of uh Russian holography uh made mostly on a Russian glass plate which is kind of difficult for shipping, but they are extremely high quality as you know and they are very interesting.
So we have like uh one wall devoted only to Russian holography.
Most of it is like uh old Russian artifacts from uh museums, but uh is uh few modern art pieces.
Quite uh interesting display I would say.
Uh the other holograms we have are uh Larry Lieberman's uh multicolor holograms.
We have some of the holograms from uh Holland from uh Dutch holography studio.
And uh we have the photopolymers which uh Hugh made uh ones using very well known masters from uh Mr.
Mr.
Ofm as well as uh Mr.
Terry.
So they're quite uh good on another show, Alex Scheimitz of Three Deep Company gave us some technical information on making the switch from Agva holographic recording materials to the new Slavic materials.
Um my group of people, and I mostly get amateurs and educational services and things of that nature at the site, that's the majority of people that come through the site, but I imagine they would be interested in two types of the emulsions, the PFG-01 and the PFD-03M.
That's true, that's what I would guess for the helium neon users.
Yes.
Now I I received a package from Slavic this week.
And it it does say PFG-01 is good for laser transmission and reflection holography.
Is that true?
Well, there's uh there's two O ones.
There's a PFG O one, which is good um as I understood it to be transmission with pulse laser or helium neon.
And then there's an O one M, which is a slight improvement.
Uh it doesn't have an anti-halo um halation backing, and it's for transmission and reflection.
I see.
And it has a greater set uh it's actually a faster emulsion than the O three.
That's right, it is a faster emulsion.
Okay, because I've got some of uh AGS older information here from their A E seventy five HD emulsions, and uh it appears to me that it may be possible to make reflection holograms with this uh dash zero one uh emulsion.
Yeah, the zero one, the analog for the zero one would be the eighty seventy five and the O one M, the analog would be an eight E seventy five H D.
Uh the O1Ms are not uh that we don't have them yet.
They won't arrive until mid-January.
Uh but at the moment we are we're reducing our buys of the O1 that's straight for transmission.
Because it looks like the O1M is really going to su uh support just about everybody's needs.
If there's our if there are special needs requiring the older the older type emulsion, of course we'd be happy to pick that up on the next uh restocking.
Dr.
Stephen Benton of the Media Lab at MIT filled HoloTalk listeners in on the latest advances in holographic technology.
Here we spoke on compressing holographic video.
Well I think the internet has made the person on the street very well aware of compression technology.
So how do compression technologies figure into this scheme with holography is it an important aspect?
Well uh certainly in holographic video uh we're uh you know we're we're making these little holograms about three inches by five inches in size size that that take thirty six megabytes each of of raw hologram data.
That's not very much actually is it?
Well you know it's not as much as it used to be this audio file will take up more space than that when we're finished.
Yeah.
Uh so uh but it's still it takes a while to pump 36 megabytes across uh from any place to any place uh if you especially if you're trying to do thirty of them a second.
So uh so we've been looking at uh compression techniques um you know we've gotten up to about thirty two to one uh with uh pretty visually lossless uh compression that's uh techniques that are designed around the specific properties of of diffractive images.
Uh Mark Lucenti who uh graduated from here a couple of years ago uh did a lot of work on what he called uh diffraction specific computing or compression and uh uh we we're gonna need that stuff when if we try to ship uh uh holographic video images moving images over any very long distances but uh did you see the men in black video covers at the store Brian Monahan from Pennsylvania Pulp and Paper talking with us about how his company created them on this HoloTalk show.
Excellent now you had a couple interesting projects and one of the ones that goes back a little way is Star Trek Generations and then you've got the men in black video covers uh video cassette cover as well.
Can you tell us a little bit about that that the men in the actually the Star Trek one was a good that you know we won uh we won a few awards with the IHMA, the International Hologram Manufacturers Association for the Star Trek doc.
Mm-hmm and it really in my opinion turned out turned out really pretty fantastic.
It achieved its goal.
The that led into a lot of other projects some smaller ones uh but then eventually into the Men in Black which uh last year uh definitely if not to date was the largest holographic packaging job in the world.
Alan Modi from Ross Books talked about a very exciting development at Sony.
This show generated the most listeners and emails of any other show.
Basically Sony just unveiled the first uh fully portable portrait holographic stereogram portrait printing system.
By portable.
Our idea of portable sometimes means like a Walkman.
Right, and it is something like that.
No kidding.
It can be used outdoors.
It's uh basically uh you sit in front of a scanning digital camera that's on a rail and the rail's about three, four feet long.
The camera travels down the rail, it takes two hundred and twenty-five uh separate images that it feeds into an image processing unit, you know, just through a wire.
Okay.
And the image processing units located in a box about the size of a desktop copying machine.
Wow.
It goes through the image processor, the Mr.
processor takes all the different parallax views and regenerates two hundred and ninety-five different views left to right, um, sends them into uh an optics board located on a little isolation platform built into this thing.
Get out.
And the uh the condensed images are well actually the images are shown on a um an L C D screen.
It's a spatial light modulator valve, they call it, and it's uh condensed into a vertical strip onto uh uh diffus diffusure screen and then it's recorded with a little green laser, um, a solid state laser, uh directly on a piece of DuPont photopolymer.
Mr.
X, who wanted to remain anonymous, spoke about his extensive collection of holograms and also spoke about holographic philosophy and David Bohm.
Now I know you follow a lot of different things with holography, including some of the theories of Dr.
David Bohm and some of the other people that uh work on that.
Uh I met him a few times and he's in well when he was alive he was a professor of theoretical physics and uh he had some really um unique ideas about you know the relationship between holograms and the universe and how possibly the cosmos is holographic in nature.
Mm-hmm.
And uh that was really interesting talking to him and discussing philosophy with him.
There's a really good book if people would be interested that deals with uh some of his ideas and with holograms and that kind of a thing and it's r fairly simple, you know, in terms of reading.
It's called a looking glass universe.
Okay.
And uh F.
David Pete and uh John Briggs are the author.
Okay.
Looking glass universe and and a couple other titles they may want to look into is uh wholeness and the implicate order.
Yeah, that's fine.
I think I think he did that maybe in conjunction with uh Christianurti.
Right, yeah.
Krishna Murti is uh philosopher.
He passed away also but some of his uh ideas I'm really appreciative of too because he deals a lot with holistic aspects of things and how the observers, the observed I asked Dr.
Jeeong from Lake Forest College about the hottest future applications of holography.
And he gave his thoughts on this and some advice for students as well.
Well XM but the big application in holography uh in the next ten years is computer memory.
Yes.
Uh H uh holographic optical element to control light inside the computer chip to distribute the information from one chip to another via light, that's the important use.
Even now the most important uses of holography, uh you know, in my I I have a Tom Pimac.
I always wear chip watches because I lose them when I'm winning.
But there's a hologram in in there that you're looking right through.
Really?
Uh used to when you push the button at night to look at what time it is, mm-hmm, there would be one little bright s light on one corner and spread out to the other side and it fades out.
Right now there's a hologram uh layer in there that spreads the light evenly throughout the entire space of my watch.
That's a hologram, nobody knows about that.
I did not know about that on the Timex watch.
Yep, in a Motorola uh cell phone, mm-hmm, you turn it on at night, there's a hologram on the on under the glass.
Isn't that interesting?
In other words, there are in lots of places.
In a C D player there's a hologram inside to split the light, send the light to different places, you know, and grocery store.
In in other words, holograms are already in many places people don't know, and in the future it'll be many other places you don't know.
That's dumpy.
And that's whole area, uh so I tell students they can have fun making holograms of pictures to to learn.
Maybe that's their profession, make art uh image, artistic images.
But by learning one thing, you automatically are learning a million things.
Yes.
To relate, you know, one learning to another.
How generic learnings are.
That one physical law applies to infinite number of things.
Ever try to do holography during an earthquake?
Steve Province of Blue Ridge Holographics filled us in on why they moved from the West Coast to the East Coast.
Uh we've been pretty fortunate.
Uh uh it was just minor stuff.
Some some clean benches crashed and HEPA filters got poked through and stuff like that.
But uh it wasn't those events that actually spooked us from uh, you know, working in Quake Country, it was the bloody aftershocks.
You know, seven or eight different elements, mm, you know, or channels, all done in a sequence, you know, tightly registered sequence.
And all of a sudden, one out of seven, for no explainable reason, the shot wouldn't come out.
Now, photoresist as as you may know, is is a very slow uh very insensitive animal.
So it pushes exposure times up into the minutes range instead of the seconds range.
And frankly, after you'd spent, you know, six hours getting through a sequence of thirteen individual recordings on a single plate, only to find that one of them dropped out because some little tremor you couldn't even feel had mucked it up, you'd have to start all over.
And after having to do every job two or three times to get lucky enough to avoid a miss, uh, we just sort of said, you know, this is counterproductive.
So we loaded up the truck and we moved from Beverly.
Lasers in airspace was just one of the topics of discussion with L.
Michael Roberts of Laser FX International.
He explained what the news is all about.
From what I understand, uh there's a hot topic in Las Vegas right now with uh you well actually between the laser light show people and the airport authorities.
Are you aware of this?
Oh yes, this has been a very hot issue in the industry and continues to be a hot issue in the industry, lasers in uh airspace.
How this came about is that uh a number of Las Vegas hotels installed very large uh laser shows to shoot beams of light into the sky as part of uh attracting people to their facilities.
And in part this used a uh new technology called the YAG laser which is an infrared laser that's been frequency doubled to five thirty two nanometers the five thirty two spectral line is very very close to the peak sensitivity of the human eye.
So for example a ten watt YAG laser would appear as bright to the human eye as a thirty or thirty five watt augon laser.
So some of these places installed thirty and forty watt and some even brighter than that and multiple uh of these lasers and shot them out into the uh night sky and they did it all in compliance with existing regulations.
But a number of uh pilots got flashed as they were coming into land and there's a perception amongst a lot of people that lasers are sort of like death rays and that if you touch it your face will melt like the guy in uh in uh writers of the lost dog.
But in actual fact the real danger is that you get momentary flash blindness.
In other words it's very similar to the effect of having your photograph taken at a dimly lit party where you sort of see that after image and you're a little startled uh just the flash of light.
The largest holograms ever created was the topic of discussion with Dr.
John Perry of holographics north.
Big holograms means big tables and he told us about his if I remember correctly from a story I read about your company maybe in Holosphere back in the eighties I would think you actually work on a floor instead of a table, right?
The the floor itself is isolated from vibration.
Did you pour like a large concrete floor or something?
That's right.
We we call it a table, but we step right onto it.
I mean it's at floor level uh frankly our landlord at the time insisted on this he wouldn't let us pour a concrete slab uh three feet above the floor.
It's twelve by twenty two feet and it's fourteen inches thick.
That's a lot of concrete and one of the advantages to floor level is of course you can just step right on it and walk around.
You don't have to climb up and climb down.
We have more headroom over it of course by doing that also.
But another advantage more practically is that someday if somebody puts that room to other uses all they have to do is tile the file the table basically and it's a floor again.
Um the uh concrete has reinforcement and it's not steel it's fiberglass reinforcement.
Um we we basically dug a huge hole um in the ground and uh and filled it up with snow uh which we have plenty of here and then poured the concrete on top of the snow and with a little blue board in between to keep the heat of the curing from from melting the snow too fast.
And then by the time the snow was melting out, the concrete had had enough to to support itself.
There are four legs that that that hold the whole thing up and a fairly complicated structure actually underneath that kind of supports all that concrete.
And that all sits on piers that go down through sleeves, uh fifteen inch diameter sleeves.
They go down about fourteen feet and then they're anchored directly into the um glacial till is really what it is, um deep under the building.
Jason Sapan of Holographic Studios in New York City.
Explain to HoloTalk listeners exactly what goes into making computer generated integral holograms.
Do you have an automated process or do you work?
The machine itself is automated, however, I would say that uh as you know, you know, the the concept of automation and holography, it's an oxymoron.
Um ninety-nine percent of the work is, you know, just manual and physical and almost debilitating at times.
Uh when it comes to computer transfer, in my case, uh I am not using a liquid crystal to project uh the images off the computer.
Uh rather I am transferring the files into a uh GIF viewer, uh projecting them on my computer monitor screen, transferring them to motion picture film one frame at a time and then running the motion picture through the uh holographic printer I have downstairs in the laboratory here, and that is automated in that, you know, it'll advance one frame of movie film, the holographic film will move and increment, and then the shutter will open, uh, it'll close, it'll wait for a settling time, it'll then advance a frame of movie film, and this is uh as tedious as can be.
We were talking many hours at work only to find out that somewhere you've carted off uh an edge of the molecule in this particular case, and you have to start over and do it all again.
So there you have it, folks.
As you know, HoloTalk has guests every other week, so that was just half of what HoloTalk listeners enjoyed during this past season.
I look forward to returning in the fall with great new programs and guests, and hope that you'll all be listening when HoloTalk returns September thirteenth to a computer near you.
It was an honor to be your host for the first year of broadcast.
Have a happy and safe summer, and I'll be seeing you in the fall.
Take care.